so this is our main thing that we're
doing today and we're going to use the
skills we just revised
to do this and just a quick thing
quick quiz when you put a whole bunch of
words together right in english
when they're all grouped together and
they have a meaning together what do we
call a group of words
a sentence that's right sentences right
now in a very similar way if you put a
bunch of algebra and numbers together
we don't tend to call it a sentence but
it's the same idea it gets a new name
starts with an e don't know it
oh now we will talk about equations but
just generally speaking
right what we call it is an expression
it's very similar but it is different
and we'll hone in on more of the
differences a bit later on mark yes
if n represents any number okay
now we actually have a way of saying
this in mathematical sort of formal
language and i'd like you to write it
down
okay and in fact even before you write
um a just write
for question one right at the top of
your heading say this
let in okay
be any number
okay that phrase there and sometimes
it'll be a different letter
sometimes it'll be slightly different
something over here but this this
particular sentence you'll see it over
and over again in math
and it's kind of like oh you know how tv
shows they have like a title card
a title like an opening sequence and
it's like 30 seconds long or something
and you know the tardis is flying around
it's like tada doctor or something like
that
for at least three minutes yeah it's a
long one summer long and so sure
uh i view this kind of like the title
card
right it's like oh now i know what we're
watching what we're looking at
is an algebra kind of um idea algebra
so there's our introduction part a
if n represents any number write an
algebraic expression
for the number added to itself well
the number
now you don't have to write the question
down but i'm going to do it because um
it's going to be easy to see if you see
it up here
okay
all they have to do is read carefully
right this admittedly is kind of like an
introduction this skill is going to be
much more useful when we do introduce
equations later
but all i want to think about is
translating this and i really mean
translating
like we're going into a different
language here algebra is its own
language
okay i'm going to take english and i'm
going to translate
into algebra okay so i see the number
there it is
the number but i just called that n
right so right there
i write down now then i say
add in that's that's addition right
that's a plus sign
yeah what do i have to add it to yeah
i was playing but that's okay n yes
there you go there's the number added to
itself
does that make sense that's it that's
all it is okay
now just as a side note you could write
it down
you could write down like we can
simplify this right
if you've got a number like say five and
you add it to itself five plus five
is ten it's the same as double
the number right that's the same however
i just wanna draw attention to the fact
that it's it's this line here
this line is the one which is equivalent
to this
these two are equivalent okay
this one this one's actually trying to
say
something a bit different that's kind of
what it's like in translation right how
many of you speak more than one language
everyone who speaks more than one
language knows
that if you want to translate right
there's lots of different ways to
translate things
right and sometimes they can both be
valid
but some translations are closer than
others okay
so in this exercise here what we're
looking for is is this line
right the one that really is the number
added to itself
that's very very very slightly different
to double the number like that's a
different
sentence so it's a different expression
does that make sense
let's do another one now again i'm
trying to teach you
how to translate what kinds of things to
look for okay now you may even like
i guess this is an advantage that i have
since i'm writing down the question okay
but i'm going to highlight the key words
that are important here when you're
translating
you don't need every single word you
just need the important ones right
so which are the important words in this
sentence and you want to suggest one to
me
yes what um
there we go if you don't know some then
it could be something completely
different
okay kieran another one number
excellent so that's the number that
we're talking about and the last
probably important one ally
fantastic okay we've got three pieces
let's put them together and that'll be
the last example you guys can have a go
you've got the number and you've got 21.
okay so i'm going to put them down
number
and 21. but then you want to know what's
the operation that combines those two
and so you look and see the word so so
what's the operation
plus addition that's it that's all there
is to it